bonsoir monsieur lamarre ont selon
monsieur fillion
il y a un an quand tout allait mal vous
parliez d'avril 2021 pour relancer les
activités du cirque finalement nous
sommes en avril 2021
c'est pas encore tout à fait le point de
départ mais on n'est pas loin
on est rendus vous êtes capable
aujourd'hui avec certitude de relancer
vos spectacles cet été
exactement à las vegas principalement
parce que eux aussi que la vaccination
se passe très très rapidement au nevada
entre aujourd'hui et l'ouverture de
notre premier spectacle 80% de la
population à las vegas sera vacciné donc
on sera dans un environnement très
sécuritaire et tous nos employés là bas
seront également vaccinés
vous serez à 100% oui exactement le
gouverneur du nevada aura levé à ce
moment là toutes les restrictions c'est
la déclaration qu'il a fait la semaine
dernière
donc ça nous permettra on va lancer aux
deux spectacles iconique c'est-à-dire
mystère et eau et par la suite il y aura
un déploiement de nos autres spectacles
à las vegas comment s'y prendre pour
repartir la machine après plus de 400
jours d'arrêt est ce que les artistes
sont au rendez vous beaucoup sans doute
on décider probablement de faire autre
chose de leur ville
il ya un an ou un beaucoup moins qu'on
ne le croyait on
on a on y rester en communication avec
eux sur une base régulière donc à las
vegas et 98 % de nos artistes qui vont
revenir pour les spectacles de tournée
on parle de 95% de nos artistes qui sont
prêts à revenir faut comprendre que pour
ces gens là c'est pas un emploi c'est
une passion et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
pensé à travers la crise qu'ils ont
lutté qu'ils ont continué à s'entraîner
et ça c'est la plus belle récompense
pour moi
on traverse avec cette crise vous
rappeler combien d'employés
on rappelle environ 200 employés à
chaque fois qu'on ouvre un spectacle
donc aujourd'hui nous étions 200
employés la semaine prochaine avec le
retour de
mystère et de haut on va rajouter un
autre 400 employés donc dès la semaine
prochaine on va être déjà 600 employés
et chaque fois que je vous annoncerai
l'ouverture d'un nouveau spectacle vous
devez ajouter 200 employés de plus alors
c'est très stimulant pour nous guérir
au fil des mois beaucoup d'emplois entre
maintenant et la fin de l'année 2020 et
vous rappeler les employés au québec
exactement donc la façon dont le ratio
d'emplois et créer c'est que lorsqu'on a
fermé à 5000 employés
il y avait environ 1200 employés à
montréal donc c'est environ un employé
sur cinq d'être au siège social
les quatre autres employés sont sur les
lieux des spectacles
donc ok quand je parle de 200 employés
donc c'est un cinquième de sa qui
viennent se greffer au siège social à
montréal donc une quarantaine sur deux
ça il ya une entente qui vient d'être
conclue pour indemniser les artistes
contractuels qui n'avait plus de travail
depuis février 2020 ont un fonds de 5
millions partagés entre 427 artistes
pourquoi ça a été si long ce délai c'est
que tout ce processus là était gérée par
la cour donc on devait passer à travers
tout un processus qui était
malheureusement beaucoup trop lent pour
nous mais surtout pour nos créateurs
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on été
commis depuis le départ et on a tenu
cette promesse là et au moment où nous
nous parlons tous ces gens l'ont était
pays et pour nous c'est très important
parce que c'est des gens qui apportent
une contribution très importante je
dirais essentiel à notre succès
artistique un an plus tard
initialement le cirque qui vient de
connaître quand même c'est la pire année
de son existence je pense que c'est à
n'en pas douter la a perdu combien
d'argent
bah écoutez vous devez calculer
plusieurs millions à chaque mois donc si
vous calculez sa part par quatorze mois
évidemment cd de multiples sites
centaines de millions de dollars qui ont
été perdus heureusement pour nous il ya
des investisseurs qui ont été près
à passer à travers la crise avec nous
parce qu'ils croient que la marque du
cirque est tellement forte que notre
retour va faire que leur investissement
va amener un retour très intéressant
pour eux et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils nous ont appuyés
malgré le fait qu on avait zéro revenus
pendant plus les quatorze morts mais des
investisseurs ont perdu de l'argent des
créanciers la caisse de dépôt a perdu
228 millions de dollars dans l'aventuré
le retour à la normale c'est pourquoi je
pense que si on avait la même entrevue à
la même date l'an prochain je pense
qu'on serait on serait là parce que
entre maintenant et la fin de l'année on
sera retournée à la normale à las vegas
et en 2022 je dirai au milieu de l'année
2022 on sera revenu tout près de la
normale pour les spectacles de tournée
donc un retour à la profitabilité dès
2000 m2 on vous souhaite du succès merci
beaucoup daniel lamarre merci à vous et
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit